hello there we just stood here in lovely
downtown austin for rtx yeah nice it's
uh quite warm so nice guys like we are
we're chucking water balloons at people
too very thoughtful keep them cool look
there's freddy w hold on holy crap do
you wanna yeah all right it's good
oh
hey
it's my good sandals what the heck man
freddy w what does that stand for freddy
wet
yeah cheeky is what you are
is going down why are you still alone
freddie what what is why are you guys
called the slow-mo guys because you guys
are slow and you last really long in bed
oh yeah hey here we go oh this is i mean
i'm you guys oh i was drinking tea shoot
things in slow motion that'll do well on
youtube we do do that i do say that as
well you did yeah i did say that i'm
upset yeah
that's it hold on
you guys want water balloon fight
i'll give you a water balloon war
wow they're going really quickly
with a towel
bollocks
hmm
um
hmm
actions
oh
we did not win that we lost we were
vastly outnumbered i know right i am
pissed
i can't believe it special thanks to
everyone from rtx who came and helped us
make that video and freddie w it was
mental never seen anything like it never
thought i could get injured by water
balloons to the
junk and the ear hole
well i hope you enjoyed it be sure to
follow us on twitter and we'll see you
in the next video at least i've cooled
down now i'm gonna go and shower
maybe we should use that one